(gentle music)
We're gonna turn our attention
back to care of children and adolescents.
Always a pleasure to welcome a friend and colleague,
Dr. Janalynn Beste.
Dr. Beste serves many roles in life,
but she's currently a professor of family medicine
at the University of North Carolina
and she's the Program Director and Chair at Novant Health
in New Hanover Regional Medical Center
Residency in Family Medicine in Wilmington.
Jan, thanks for being here. It's a pleasure.
Good afternoon.
Thank you.
So I'm gonna talk to you about some fun topics today.
I'm gonna talk to you about kids.
So my practice, I'm a residency director.
Our residency practice has about,
35% of our patients are under the age of 18.
So we've gotten very good at taking care of kids,
so I'll try to throw in some pearls as well as board stuff.
I have nothing to disclose.
These are our learning objectives. We're gonna get going.
Let's talk a little bit about newborn screening tests.
The USPSTF, unlike everything else you know about,
has no say in screening tests with newborns
for inherited diseases.
That's something through
the Department of Health and Human Services.
They have an advisory committee
and they have a long list of recommended screening tests.
Most of you have seen some of these.
There's the metabolic disorders,
there's the hemoglobinopathies,
there's the endocrine disorders,
and then there's some other just multi-system disorders.
Now, as you probably all know,
every state has a different panel that they require.
These are the ones recommended by
the U.S. Department of Health and Human Services.
Okay, so for those of you who maybe haven't practiced
newborn care in a while, there may be some new tests
out there that you're not aware of
and this may be one of them.
This is a recommended screening test
for congenital heart defects,
and so these are your heart defects that
typically cause you to become hypoxemic.
So you can see the the big targets for this:
your hypoplastic left heart, your Tetrology of Fallot,
your transposition of the great arteries.
So how do you test for this?
So basically, you take your baby
and they have to be over 24 hours of age.
Why do they have to be over 24 hours of age?
Sorry, I felt like I was talking to my residents;
I was waiting for somebody to raise their hand.
So the reason is because the ductus arteriosus closes
and they go from fetal circulation
to extra uterine circulation.
So you have to wait that 24 hours, and then you put
a pulse ox on their right hand and on one of their feet
and you measure their oxygen levels.
It should be above 95%
in both the right hand and the right foot,
and there should be less than a 3% difference
between those two.
If they don't pass that one, you say,
"Okay, maybe this kid's a little slow;
let's give them another hour."
You check it again.
They don't pass that one, you give 'em one more chance,
and if they don't pass that,
then they go for an echocardiogram.
So two failed screens are,
or if your oximetry is less than 90% at any time,
just send them for an echocardiogram.
Okay, the other screening test
that's maybe new for some of you
is universal screening for hearing loss in newborns,
and that's because 50% of newborns
have no identifiable risk factors;
so they recommend screen all of them.
And so as you know, the reason why we screen for things
is because we have things that we can do about it.
And so it's been shown that if you screen them
and diagnose them early and refer them for treatment,
they actually have better language skills
by the time they hit school.
So this is a screening test that actually has good outcomes
if we do something about it.
If you see a kid in your practice
fail their newborn screen, you need to make sure
they have followed up by three months.
Developmental dysplasia of the hip.
Somehow this shows up on boards randomly,
so I thought I'd take a minute and go over it.
So your risk factors in infants
are not great predictive values, but if you have a child
who was breached in the third trimester,
even if they turned vertex at the end;
so if they had a version and turned vertex,
they're still counted as someone with a risk factor.
Here's a trick or a tip.
Anytime in pediatrics that there's a family history,
the child is almost always at a higher risk,
so just keep that in mind.
If there's a family history
of developmental dysplasia of the hip,
child is at higher risk.
Or if you have a history of improper swaddling,
this always image to me is very funny
because it's the hips extended and abducted,
which basically means they're wrapping 'em like a mummy.
I don't know anybody who wraps their babies like that,
but if you do that, that's not good.
So how do you test this?
This is where you put your hands behind the hips
and you try to posteriorly dislocate the femur,
and you should feel a clunk.
If you feel a click or you're like,
"I'm not sure what that is," it's not it.
It needs to be a clunk.
The board question is often, "What do you do with that?"
You refer them to orthopedics.
You do not get an ultrasound. You don't get an X-ray.
You just send them straight to orthopedics
if you fail that on your exam.
The ultrasound is not accurate until about 6 weeks of age.
Once those little bony centers start ossifying,
you start doing X-rays, which is about four to six months,
and you should do this up until they're walking
because this is developmental.
Okay, there is one, a recommendation from the USPSTF,
and that is to put ocular prophylaxis for gonorrhea
in their eyes at birth.
And erythromycin is the drug that we use.
You'll see most of the nursing staff,
or if you're doing this at home births,
they'll do this within the first few hours of life.
Okay, our first question.
First question is about Vitamin D.
How much Vitamin D supplementation do infants need
during the first month of life?
Breastfed infants should have
400 international units of Vitamin D daily,
Milk-based formula-fed infants do not need
any Vitamin D supplementation,
Infants fed combined breastmilk and milk-based formula
should have 200 international units of Vitamin D,
or No Vitamin D supplementation is needed
during the first month of life.
All right, excellent. About half of you got it right.
So let's talk about Vitamin D.
So breastmilk does not have a lot of Vitamin D in it,
but all infants should have Vitamin D
starting the first few days of life.
So formula-fed infants finally get enough Vitamin D
once they're taking about a liter or 32 ounces
of Vitamin D-fortified formula.
Somewhere around three to four months of age,
unless some of my parents two weeks of age
have already said, "I don't know why my baby's spitting up.
Been feeding them 32 ounces of formula."
Breastfed infants should continue on Vitamin D
up until they're on Vitamin D-fortified milk,
so typically around a year of age.
Or, breastfeeding mothers can take
6,400 international units of Vitamin D.
That's the official number.
Obviously, they can take 10,000 a day.
So the other supplementation,
so Vitamin D for all babies
starting within a few days of birth,
iron supplementation is for your breastfed infants
starting one milligram per kilogram per day
starting at four months.
Babies are born with iron stores,
but around four months of age they start to peter out,
so this is where you start your breastfed infants on iron.
Formula-fed infants, please make sure they're taking
iron-fortified formula.
Now, there's something different for premature infants,
and premature is less than 37 weeks.
All of those infants should be put on iron,
whether they're breastfeeding or iron.
You see there's two different doses for breastfeeding,
it's a little bit higher,
it's two milligrams per kilogram per day,
whereas for formula feeding
it's one milligram per kilogram per day.
And that's for the whole first year of life
for premature infants;
so if you take care of preemies in your office,
please be aware you have to think about Vitamin D and iron.
So breastfeeding.
Six months of exclusive breastfeeding is recommended
by the American Academy of Pediatrics.
They recommend then starting food at six months of age
and then breastfeeding can continue
as long as mom and baby desire.
That can be up to two years of age
or even longer in some places.
Couple of things that have been shown
to help with breastfeeding.
Those of you who have either been in a delivery room,
or heard about delivery rooms,
or have families in delivery rooms,
know that no longer do we take the baby
and whisk them away over to the warmer.
We actually hand the baby to the mom
and they put the baby right on the mom's chest.
That's called skin-to-skin.
It does improve breastfeeding rates.
It also helps with temperature regulation,
breathing, heart rate, all the things that we want
that are good for babies.
Professional and layperson support
also increases breastfeeding rates, so that's help.
You can actually monitor
their milk intake by weighing them.
So if you have a mom who's like,
"This baby's getting no milk,"
you can actually weigh them before and after a feeding.
And if they have tongue tie,
fixing that tongue tie will often help
with nipple-related pain,
and if you can fix mom's nipple-related pain,
she's more likely to breastfeed.
Lots and lots of baby benefits for breastfeeding;
so you can see the whole list here.
The ones most of us know about is obesity
and otitis and infections;
you may not know diabetes, hypertension.
Look at all these great things breastfeeding helps with.
Maternal benefits may be a little less well-defined,
but we do know there's a decreased risk of breast cancer,
ovarian cancer, endometrial cancer;
and also, look at that, diabetes and hypertension.
There's not a lot of contraindications.
I don't know about you, but I don't see
a lot of Ebola or untreated brucellosis.
The biggest ones that I see
are maternal active, maternal substance use
because, obviously, anything that's going into the mom
will be going into the baby;
so you need to have a pretty significant conversation
with your mom about that.
I find that mostly conversations with my moms
who are recreational marijuana users
in a state where it is not legal.
And whether it's legal or not, it doesn't matter.
There's some impact for the baby.
Okay, some feeding pearls.
If they are using formula, please make sure
they're using iron formula.
It should be at room temperature;
don't heat it in the microwave.
Make sure that you switch to
Vitamin D-fortified cow's milk at one year.
You can use soy formula
for those who are vegetarian families
or have some histories of allergies.
Recommendation to start foods, not a lot of evidence-based.
This is sort of the C recommendations.
Start cereals about four to six months.
Vegetables, fruits and table foods.
Don't do honey in the first year.
And, so this is something that does come up on the boards.
If you're at a high risk for peanut allergy,
so if there's a lot of peanut allergies in the family,
you should introduce peanut containing foods
in those first set of foods.
So not peanuts, just to be clear;
like peanut butter or something else that contains peanuts.
Had somebody ask me that:
"Oh, should I just give my kid peanuts?"
No, don't give your kid peanuts.
Here's your nutrition pearls.
Babies should have a couple of stools a day,
several wet diapers a day.
They should regain their birth weight
in the first two weeks.
They can lose up to 10% of their body weight
in that first two weeks and then regain it,
and they should double their birth weight
by four to six months, triple at a year.
Okay, next question.
Following a scheduled repeat C-section delivery,
a term infant has a respiratory rate greater than 60.
What is the treatment for the most common cause
of this condition?
So, do you do a septic workup and antibiotics,
do you do a chest tube,
do intubation and suction immediately after delivery,
or do you supportive care with oxygen?
Excellent.
Most of you realize that you should be
doing supportive care with oxygen
because this is transient to get of the newborn.
This is the most common cause of respiratory distress,
unfortunately, in newborns, up to a half of them.
It's a diagnosis of exclusion;
you can't assume that's what it is
until you've looked at everything else.
If you did a chest X-ray, you'd see some diffuse,
sort of patchy infiltrates.
We used to call this retained fetal lung fluid,
for those of you who may be a little bit older.
Most of the time, it goes away quickly.
It can last 72 hours.
The longest I ever saw was five days, stumped all of us.
And all you do is you put them on oxygen,
give them some nasal CPAP, and wait for it to go away
after you've made sure it's not one of these things.
So if they are a premature infant,
you need to think about respiratory distress syndrome.
If they had meconium, think about meconium aspiration.
Obviously, if there was a history of a maternal,
like untreated GBS or something like that,
you need to think about pneumonia.
And, of course, if maybe they had to have
some positive pressure ventilation, you might need
to think about a pneumothorax.
Heart murmurs.
Again, if you don't see them in the hospital,
you may see them in your office
and the mom say, "Oh my gosh, my baby had a heart murmur."
Most heart murmurs are transitional and benign.
So the most common thing we see is right after delivery,
you're hearing a murmur because you're starting
to hear that ductus arteriosus as it's closing,
and then 24 hours later it's gone.
It's really fun to do with medical students.
Pathologic murmurs are your loud murmurs,
your harsh murmurs, continuous murmurs,
and anytime the kid doesn't look good,
the kid's turning blue while feeding or is lethargic.
Don't blow off that murmur. None of you would anyway.
Okay, next question.
Let's talk about breastfeeding,
another big one on the boards.
Breastfeeding jaundice is characterized by:
Onset after seven days of life,
Persistence longer than one month of life,
Insufficient feeds, or Frequent stools.
All right, excellent, about half of you realize
that this is insufficient feeding.
So let's back up a little bit and talk a little bit
about physiologic jaundice.
So newborns conjugate bilirubin slower,
they have more red blood cells being busted up
after that delivery, and they have decreased excretion;
and so physiologically they do have a rise.
If you tested bilirubin on all babies, which we do,
you will see usually a little bit
of a rise in that bilirubin just normally.
It peaks a couple of days, three to five days after birth,
and usually by two weeks it's fine.
In preterm infants, all of this is magnified.
So they tend to go to higher levels,
they tend to last longer
because their livers are even less prepared to handle this
than a term infant is.
So neonatal hyper bilirubin is
a total serum or plasma bilirubin
greater than the 95th percentile
on the hour-specific Bhutani nomogram,
which is a nice little chart that tells you
how high the bilirubin should be at each hour of life.
And I'm gonna point out,
for those of you who either were not aware
or just want to do some fun extra reading,
the American Academy of Pediatrics put out
some new hyperbilirubinemia guidelines
for the first time in quite some time in 2022;
and so I'm gonna go through some of the changes
that they said there.
So they recommend that they do universal newborn screening.
You can do targeted screening;
I don't know anybody who does target screening.
So what is severe hyperbilirubinemia?
If you get a total bilirubin greater than 20,
that's considered severe.
And why do we worry about this?
Well, bilirubin crosses the blood-brain barrier
and can attach to the brain tissue
and can cause neurologic dysfunction.
So you can have the acute bilirubin encephalopathy,
or if you leave it alone,
it can actually turn into permanent brain damage,
which is kernicterus.
Okay, so you have babies who are at risk
for developing hyperbilirubinemia,
so the risk of getting that bilirubin above 20.
And you'll see this nice long list;
I'm gonna point out a few things.
One is exclusive breastfeeding with suboptimal intake.
That was our board question we talked about.
Oh, look at this: parent or sibling received phototherapy.
Remember what I said, if it's in the family,
they're more likely to have it as well.
Lower gestational age.
The earlier the baby is, the more likely they are
to develop severe hyperbilirubinemia.
Hemolytic disease.
And the one thing I wanna point out, so this is something
that was new in the last set of guidelines.
This family history of genetic ancestry
suggestive of inherited RBC disorders
including glucose-6-phosphate dehydrogenase deficiency.
I remember learning about that
and I never really thought about it,
but I want you to look at those numbers:
13% of African American males
and 4% of African American females have G6PD deficiency.
Over the past few years,
almost all of our people who unexpectedly,
you know, bottle feeding moms, the bilirubin went to 20,
had G6PD deficiency, so think about that.
So of the kids who get that really high bilirubin level,
these are the kids at risk for having neurotoxicity.
So if they have a low albumin,
if they have G6PD deficiency, if they are premature
and if they're septic or have clinical instability.
Okay, one of the nice things is
that breastfeeding jaundice, they switched the name.
It's now suboptimal intake hyperbilirubinemia,
which I think makes it a little more obvious
as to what it is.
People used to confuse it with breastmilk jaundice.
So breastfeeding jaundice is essentially
an exaggeration of the normal physiologic jaundice.
It's the baby's not taking in enough,
and usually they're feeding less than eight times a day,
and so they aren't pooping out enough
and the bilirubin just raises up.
So what do you do? Tell mom to feed the baby more.
You don't stop breastfeeding.
You see that interrupting breastfeeding
decreases your chances of success,
and you can have them continue to breastfeed
and usually tell them more frequently.
I find this most often when they've been told
you have to feed the baby every three hours.
And anybody who's had a newborn knows
babies don't feed on anybody's schedule;
they feed when they're hungry,
and that could be every 30 minutes.
Breastmilk jaundice is a factor in breastmilk
and it's usually not quite so high a level
and it lasts a long time;
so it sort of rises slowly
and it can last up to a couple of months.
So how do you treat it? You treat the underlying cause.
If it's insufficient breastfeeding,
they need to feed more frequently,
so 8 plus times, I tell moms,
10 to 12 times in 24 hours, give or take.
There's nice tools out there.
You can use online tools, or an app;
BiliTool is one that we use.
You can risk stratified and put in the bilirubin level
and say, "Are we at a level where we need
to think about treatment?"
If you're going to treat, you treat with phototherapy.
If you are high enough, you need to talk to your friends
in neonatology world about an exchange transfusion.
And again, if that jaundice persists,
you need to think about something else;
is there some other disease process going on?
Failure to stool.
Most of your babies will poop that thick black meconium
in the first 12 hours of life.
After 24 hours, please go and examine the baby.
I always remember when I was a resident,
one of my classmates missed the fact
that the baby had an imperfect anus.
He never lived that down;
that went all throughout his career with him.
And other things like cystic fibrosis,
Hirschsprung's, et cetera.
Okay, constipation: the bane of all of our existence.
Moms come in, "Oh my gosh, my baby's constipated."
You put in the thermometer and,
boom, they poop and you fix them.
So if that doesn't work, there's other things you can do.
One is glycerin suppositories when they get old enough.
You can do some of the high-fiber fruit juices.
Miralax over the age of six months,
you're gonna hear Miralax a lot, polyethylene glycol.
High-fiber foods once they get older:
that helps prevent constipation,
it doesn't treat constipation.
So think about if they come into you
and they truly are constipated, you have to treat first
before you start talking about putting 'em on prevention.
Reflux.
So there are two different things
when you want to think about reflux.
There is gastroesophageal reflux
and gastroesophageal reflux disease.
What's the difference?
Reflux, pretty common and pretty normal;
it's your happy spitters.
You have a normal exam, weight gain,
they're happy, they spit up,
and basically you tell the mom,
"They're growing good. Everything's fine.
"Just make sure to always carry
a couple changes of clothing with you."
With the disease, then you have poor weight gain.
They may be coughing, wheezing, seeming uncomfortable,
and that's the group that you think about treating.
So you can talk about thickened feedings
to try to minimize regurgitation.
You can use H2 blockers.
We don't have a lot of great evidence for PPIs in infants.
Sometimes when I send them to to PEDS GI,
they will come back on that, but that's usually after
we've tried everything else.
You can try soy or hydrolyzed formulas
and see if that makes a difference.
You can try changing maternal diet
to see if that makes a difference.
Pyloric stenosis, this is a fun board question.
And they'll always give you the classic case,
which is a four-week-old white boy
with nonbilious and projectile vomiting
who throws up, seems hungry,
eats, throws up, seems hungry.
So that's sort of a classic board question.
But other causes of vomiting...
In my personal practice, the most common cause of vomiting
is overfeeding those 32 ounces per day
in the first two weeks of life.
We already talked about reflux.
And if the child looks ill, you need to think about
more serious conditions like gastroenteritis, volvulus.
And don't forget that shaken baby syndrome often presents
with a child who's vomiting, so keep that in mind.
Colic, known as the 10th circle of hell
for parents who've experienced it,
is uncontrollable crying for three hours per day,
more than three days per week for longer than three weeks.
The baby looks great in terms of weight gain,
everything else is fine.
Oh my gosh, it's the parents, though, who look terrible.
The parents are haggard and thinking, "I'm a terrible mom.
Somebody's gonna take this child away from me."
There are some evidence-based things you can actually do.
So if mom is breastfeeding,
you can eliminate some allergens.
You can actually give the baby the probiotic Lactobacillus
in breastfeeding, but not formula-fed infants.
With formula-fed infants, you can try switching
to a hydrolyzed formula for a period of time
and see if that helps.
And most of them,
thank god for the future of the human race,
outgrow this by six months of age.
I almost returned my son to sender when he had colic,
and I'd gone back to working full time.
Okay, undescended testicles
are more common in premature boys.
Most of the time, they descend by six months of age.
So if you have a six-month-old child check,
if you still can't feel those testicles,
you need to refer them over to urology.
And they will usually talk about surgery
somewhere around 9 months of age,
9 months to 12 months of age.
So surgery will help preserve fertility.
However, they still have
a higher risk of testicular cancer.
And that's something you need to tell the parents
to make sure that they've told the child
when he gets of an age to be
paying attention to such things.
And they can have testicular atrophy
as a complication of surgery.
I find that a lot of our surgeons don't discuss that.
I've actually had one of my patients
who had that complication from surgery
and they were unaware.
Okay, this is one of the scariest things
I've ever seen in my career,
and that is neonatal herpes simplex.
It can present one of three ways.
So it can present as just a localized skin infection,
you know, like your herpetic whitlow kind of a thing.
It can be in the central nervous system, so meningitis.
Or, it can become disseminated disease,
which was the case that I saw;
and it has a 60% mortality rate
even with appropriate treatment.
Now, those of you who are like,
"Well, I practice outpatient medicine,
why do I need to worry about that?"
Even if they have just the localized skin infection,
so if you see a baby with a cold sore
or with a little skin infection,
you need to treat them with IV acyclovir
because it can turn into disseminated disease
with 60% mortality.
Okay, hepatitis B.
If you have a mom who is hepatitis B antigen positive,
you'll give them both the vaccine and the immunoglobulin
within the first 12 hours of birth.
Now, let's say, mom, you don't know.
You can give the hepatitis B vaccine as you normally would
and then you can test the mom, and you have up until a week
to give the immunoglobulins.
So if you're following up a baby from the hospital,
if you don't take care of them in the hospital,
that's something you'd want to know
is I need to follow those results and see about
getting that given to the baby in that first week of life.
What advice would you give parents to reduce
the risk of death from sudden infant death syndrome,
SIDS, in their infant?
Would you tell them to stop breastfeeding,
would you tell them that you should
avoid exposure of the infant to second-hand smoke,
you should place the baby in the prone position for sleep,
or you should discourage the use of a pacifier?
Okay. Oh, excellent.
Most of you knew you should avoid exposure of the infant
to secondhand smoke.
So sudden infant death syndrome,
peak incidence is at two to three months of age.
And the things that you have to worry, those risk factors,
are prone position...
After Covid, if y'all don't know what proning is...
We all have that burned into our minds right now.
Proning is that face down position.
Bed sharing, especially if mom or dad,
or whoever's sharing the bed with them is impaired.
Cigarette smoke exposure. All those things are bad.
Protective: pacifiers, fans, and breastfeeding;
all of those are good.
And like with all of healthcare,
there are some significant racial disparities.
Sleep.
So the American Academy of Pediatrics
has a bunch of recommendations about sleep.
Put the baby on their back
every single time for every single sleep.
Skin-to-skin, we talked about that.
Firm, safe, flat sleep surface. Breastfeeding recommended.
The baby should have their own little bed
in close proximity to the mom for breastfeeding.
Don't overheat them.
Recommended that infants sleep in the parent's room,
close to the parent's bed on a separate surface
designed for infants, ideally for at least
the first six months.
And no naps in cars or strollers,
(chuckles) written by somebody who's never had children.
Okay, last question.
The majority of failure to thrive cases
in infants is due to:
celiac disease, malabsorption syndrome,
hyperthyroidism, or inadequate caloric intake.
Excellent, inadequate caloric intake,
so it's now growth faltering.
It's basically inadequate growth, physical growth.
You can't take just one point
and say they have failure to thrive or growth faltering.
You have to look at it over a couple of points.
It occurs pretty frequently.
You will see this if you take care of children
in your practice.
And the most common cause, by far,
is just not enough calories.
So why are they not getting enough calories?
Maybe mom or dad is not preparing the formula correctly.
Maybe they're having bad reflux and disease.
Maybe there's just neglect and nobody's remembering
to feed the baby, had a couple of those.
"I thought you fed the baby." "I thought you fed the baby."
Mechanical feeding problems.
There are some times where they have inadequate absorption,
like milk allergies or deficiencies.
And, of course, increased metabolism;
so if they have hyperthyroidism.
Down syndrome is another one
that can cause increased metabolism.
All of those can cause the baby to be burning more calories
than they're taking in.
So how do you treat it?
Well, like everything else, what's the underlying cause?
If it's a inadequate calorie intake,
you're going to think about a high calorie diet
and you're going to make sure the parents
are mixing formulas correctly,
mom is feeding the baby frequently enough
if she's breastfeeding.
And if that doesn't seem to work,
you may need to look at some other potential causes,
so here's some of the tests you would order.
You really should try not to hospitalize
if at all possible.
We sometimes do because we have a population
with a lot of social risk factors
and sometimes by hospitalizing it's the only way
we can actually observe what's going on with the family.
Most of the time, you do not need to hospitalize them.
Okay, a couple last little bits and pieces.
Lacrimal duct obstruction.
Persistent tearing usually on one side.
So mom will come and say, "This eye is always crusting.
"Every time I wake up, I have to wipe it out
every time the baby wakes up."
So you can try putting some warm compresses on it,
milking the duct;
you don't need to do anything else.
Keep an eye on it.
Usually, if by a year it's still there,
then you need to send them to an ophthalmologist
to have them probe open that duct.
So most of the parents have gotten that message
about putting the baby on their back to sleep,
and so they put them on their back in the car seat
and put them on their back in the swing
and they put them on their back in the bed;
and they end up with positional plagiocephaly,
which is some flattening in the back of the head.
I think you've probably all seen these.
Oftentimes, it'll be on one side
because the baby usually will have
a preferred side that they like to sleep on.
So make sure that you're switching the head position
and make sure they're doing tummy time.
So tell the parents they only have to be
on their back while they're sleeping.
If you're in there with them or they're awake,
put them on their tummy so they can practice,
you know, putting their head up
and also take the pressure off the back of the head.
And if you have a kid who has that
positional plagiocephaly on one side,
make sure they don't have torticollis.
Had a resident one time whose baby had that
and she felt terrible that she had missed that,
and I said, "Well, who would've thought?"
Okay, frequent flyers. We talked about this.
Hip dysplasia screening, breastfeeding,
hyperbilirubinemia, Vitamin D, SIDS prevention.
And here are your answers, in case y'all missed it.
So thank you very much.
(gentle music)